[Music]
hey everyone thanks for tuning in and
welcome to my talk
my name is tom barkley and i am the lab
director at
trichome analytical
trichome is a third party cannabis
testing lab located in new jersey
and the topic of my talk today has to do
with
standardization
in cannabis
pesticide testing
particularly the standardization of
pesticide testing analytical methods
so today i'll be presenting a method
that i've been developing to meet the
aoac standard method performance
requirements
so pesticides of course refer to
various different types of chemicals
that are
intended to
prevent pests
the epa
definition is a little bit more broad
and does include other things like
plant regulators
defoliants desiccants and nitrogen
stabilizers
currently the epa has over
300 pesticide chemicals that are
registered for use
as pesticides
and currently there are 59
pesticide products that are registered
for use
by the epa specifically for hemp
and hemp of course is the only currently
federally legal
form of cannabis
and out of this 59 pesticide products
58
have active ingredients that are
considered to be bio pesticides
and the one pesticide chemical listed as
a conventional pesticide
has an
active ingredient of
potassium salts of fatty acids so these
are all relatively non-toxic
and relatively safe chemicals
and because of the legal status of
cannabis
in the united states it is very much
regulated on a state-by-state basis
with many of the states having their own
programs and actual pesticide rules
so many many times the states will
divide up their cannabis programs
based on either recreational
medical and hemp
and hemp is also sometimes referred to
as cbd or low thc
and i just wanted to highlight
the
medical cannabis market in particular
and uh do a quick comparison of the
different state pesticide testing rules
and
kind of highlight the issue that there
is with the lack of harmonization
between these states and their pesticide
rules
so this chart is from a paper published
last year in the current research and
toxicology
and in this study they did a survey of
the pesticide testing
regulations in jurisdictions
and states within the united states
and this is specifically for medical
cannabis programs
and what they found is that there is a
total of 98 insecticides that are
regulated across the 21
of the uh
the surveyed jurisdictions in the study
but almost half of these were only
regulated in a single jurisdiction out
of out of the total number
so basically
what this means is that every state kind
of has their own
pesticide
list for cannabis and so there is
definitely this lack of harmonization
between states
and then also in the same study
they did look at the differences in
action levels for the pesticides that
were regulated
by more than one state
and again
they found a pretty broad range of of
action limits um some of these uh
chemical pesticides you can see here
range in having action levels from
you know up to three orders of magnitude
difference between the different
programs and that's represented here
with these gray lines
with the median
action action level represented by the
the yellow
circle in these charts
and the lack of standardization also
exists for
specifically for
pesticide cannabis testing methods
analytical methods
and
shown here are the results from
an interlaboratory
pesticide and cannabis
proficiency test so this is the 2021
emerald test which is
specifically for pesticide and hemp
flour
so for this test each lab was supplied
with a spiking solution
containing the the pesticides to be
tested
as well as a blank hemp matrix material
and the labs were instructed to spike
the pesticides directly into the hemp
and then quantitate with
their own
methods that they utilize in
in each lab
and shown in this chart are the interlab
percent relative standard deviations
of the measured
concentrations for each pesticide in
this study
and these are listed
uh based on their assigned concentration
which is shown at the top of the graph
and you can see that there is a fair
amount of variability here so
approximately half of these
pesticide analytes have
a percent rst that is greater than 30.
and i think this probably can be
attributed to the fact that
each lab is pretty much running their
own
internally developed method and there is
no
standard method being utilized for this
type of analysis
and then also as the lab director at
trichome analytical
i have to deal with
pesticide testing pretty much every day
at the lab
we test various different types of
cannabis
hemp which comes from
different states throughout the country
we also test medical cannabis which
comes from
uh in-state in new jersey the new jersey
medical cannabis program
and we are also awaiting for
the
final testing regulations for new
jersey's recreational cannabis program
so there's definitely a lot to keep
track of as far as the regulations
and you know there is a lot of
complexity when it comes to
multi-residue pesticide analysis so
we are definitely always looking for
ways to try to
uh simplify our methods
and kind of harmonize the the different
testing methods that we utilize in our
lab so
recently we were looking for ways to get
involved in contributing towards the
development of a standardized method for
pesticides and cannabis
and there are a number of standards
organizations that are
getting more involved in cannabis and
one of those is aoac
aoac has a very active cannabis
program called the cannabis analytical
science program
or casp
and in 2018 they published a
standard method performance requirement
for
the quantitation of pesticides in
dried cannabis materials
so the purpose of an smpr
in general is to serve as a guide for
labs to submit possible methods for
consideration
as a standard method
and some of the highlights for the
for the smpr for pesticides in cannabis
in particular
is shown here and
there are a number of requirements such
as the
total number of pesticides to be tested
for in this
case there are 104
and within that list of 104 is pretty
much any
united states
requirement for an individual state
cannabis program and that includes
california
and also canada in that list
and there are a number of other
requirements such as the percent
recovery
repeatability
and reproducibility of the method
and then in addition
uh each pesticide has a recommended
action limit and a limit of quantitation
so we basically wanted to see if we
could
develop a method that would
meet all of these requirements in the
aoac smpr
and so as a starting point for this
project i wanted to
utilize our current
in-house lab method for pesticides in
cannabis
in that method you know we utilize both
gcms and lcms
those are both triple quad instruments
and we also use a single extraction step
and a relatively simple clean up process
for this
project we also were able to collaborate
with shimazu scientific and millipore
sigma for their help in the method
development process
so one of the first things that i wanted
to explore with this method was the
extraction solvent
and i had some prior experience
working with one of the pesticides in
the aoac list which is ethaphon
and ethaphon is not extracted very well
using acetonitrile so
i wanted to try to use methanol
methanol is commonly used in the lab
particularly for cannabis and extracting
cannabinoids
and what i found was that methanol does
actually work a lot better for
extracting ethaphon
from hemp compared to
acetonitrile and
the percent recovery that i measured for
acetonitrile was around 10 percent
but with methanol it was around
90 percent uh for for ethaphon being
extracted from hemp
and that's shown here in the bottom left
of the slide these are
lcms chromatograms
and you can also see here on the right
side of this slide
these are superimposed chromatograms of
epiphone
extracted with various mixes of
acetonitrile and methanol as the
extraction solvent
and you can see that as the
percentage of methanol increases
from
100
or from 10 methanol in the black trace
up to 100 methanol in the orange trace
uh that the peak response increases as
well which indicates the
better extraction efficiency
unfortunately the problem with methanol
is that it does appear to
co-extract some of those more
undesirable matrix components
that can be problematic such as
chlorophyll
and you can see here on the left
image this is a comparison of
the just the visual color of the extract
acetone nitrile versus methanol you
could see that the methanol extract has
a much darker green color
and then even after the cleanup
which
we're using a
c18 solid phase extraction cartridge
even after that process there's a lot of
that green
uh color left in the extract
for the for the methanol extract
and so for these reasons and the
difficulties with cleanup
for this method i decided to stay with
acetonitrile as the extraction solvent
and not use methanol
so
here is the sample preparation
uh steps for this method
so the method uses a
half a gram of cannabis laid out into a
centrifuge tube
three milliliters of acetonitrile is
added
which is acidified with one percent
acetic acid
after vortex mixing and centrifugation
the extract is cleaned up using a
c18 solid phase extraction
pass-through cartridge
the cartridge is then flushed
additionally with one milliliter of
acetonitrile
and that final diluted and cleaned
extract can be analyzed directly by
lcms and gcms
and then shown on the bottom left of
this slide are the different steps at
which the internal standard
and the pesticide spiking solutions are
added
depending on the sample type
so for the spikes
the spiking solution
containing the target pesticides as well
as the internal standard are added
directly to the cannabis before
extraction
whereas for the
calibration standards
the
the
spiking solution
and the internal standards are added
during step two
after the extraction solvent has been
added
the calibration for this method utilizes
an eight point calibration curve
the standards are matrix matched and
a total of 87 of the pesticides are
quantitated by lcms
with the remaining 15 being quantitated
by gcms
here are the instrument parameters for
lcms
the instrument that i used for this
method development is a shimadzu lcms
8060
with electrospray ionization
operating in both positive and negative
mode
the
the method here is a
reverse phase method with a two
microliter
injection volume
and the initial mobile phase condition
is 100 aqueous
and i found that that helped with the
with the elution of the polar pesticides
in this method
for gcms i used a
shimazu
tq8040nx
the injection volume was two microliters
and this is a splitless high pressure
injection
so in order to test the method
performance
i spiked the target pesticides in three
different
cannabis matrices
and i really wanted to see the
difference in performance for these
different types of cannabis
and those those different
types of cannabis are shown here so i
use a cbd biomass which has a relatively
low
concentration of
cannabinoids
due to the fact that's going to have
some more leaves and stems mixed in with
it
and then also i utilized a cbd flower
and a thc flower
the cannabinoid concentrations are shown
here these are tested
in-house with our
cannabinoid potency method
the spiking solution level
or
i should say the
pesticide spiking level in the cannabis
was 100 nanograms per gram
and for those pesticides having limits
of quantitation that were greater than
100 nanograms per gram i spiked at one
microgram per gram
and then also
the important thing to note here is that
the blank material that was used to
matrix match the calibration standards
was the cbd biomass
so here are the spike recovery results
for the first half
of the lcms pesticides
the second half is shown on the next
slide
and these results are ordered by the
retention time so the earlier alluding
pesticides are to the left the later
alluders are to the right
and the horizontal dotted lines
represent the aoac
acceptable range for the percent
recovery and that's between
60 and 120
and
overall you can see that the percent
recovery for the cbd biomass
is well within the acceptance limits
being between 60 and 120 percent
there were a few pesticides that are
outside of the acceptance range for the
cbd flower and the thc flower
and here are the results for the second
half of the lcms percent recovery data
so this is for the compounds that are
alluding later in the run between 5
minutes and 11 minutes
and there are are a few interesting
things going on
with this data
the first is that the cbd biomass again
is
uh the recoveries there are well within
the acceptance range however there are a
number of
results for the cbd and thc flowers that
are outside of the acceptance range
and
basically my interpretation of this is
that
this is due to the matrix suppression
and enhancement effects within the lcms
which is going to be dependent on the
actual strain
and i think this makes sense also given
the fact that
the
non-polar
co-extracted matrix components
such as the cannabinoids are
expected to be alluding in this part of
the run
as opposed to the earlier part of the
run which was shown in the previous
slide where the percent recoveries were
quite good
for all three of the matrices
and then again you can really see the
difference between the cbd biomass
which was
specifically used as the material to
matrix match the calibration standards
compared to the results for those flower
samples
and then moving on to the gcms
spike recovery results
you can see again that all of the tested
analytes
are within the acceptance range for the
cbd biomass
some of the later alluding pesticides
such as deltimethrin cyphermethrin and
ciphluthrin had low
unacceptable results for
the cbg flower and thc flower
so to summarize the performance of this
method
there were two of the aoac
pesticides of which could not be
quantitated and those were ethaphon and
a proteon
so epiphone i mentioned earlier that was
an issue with the extraction solvent
a proteon i found
to have a strong interference by both
gcms and lcms
in this chromatogram
on this slide which is which is gcms you
can see
a comparison between
the same level of a proteon in
acetonitrile versus
in a matrix extract
and there is a significant interference
there which may be due to the
cannabinoids
so out of the
pesticides they could be quantitated
with this method there are a total
of 102
and all of them that met the percent
recovery and repeatability requirements
of the aoac
smpr
for the single spike level that was
tested in this study
and the big caveat here is that the same
batch of hemp
or cannabis used for spiking also needed
to be used for the matrix matched
calibration standards
and then also for the
aoac recommended action limits or limits
of quantitation
there were a total of eight pesticides
which could not meet
the action limits that were specified by
aoic as specifically being
action limits that were based on a
survey of regulations
in the united states and canada which
was part of that smpr
the interesting thing about
these these eight pesticides here is
that they do
the the performance of this method
for for the limits of quantitation
for those pesticides
does meet the action levels for
uh various states that i've shown here
such as california
the new york cannabinoid hemp program
and also new jersey's interim testing
standards so you can see that the aoac
recommended limits are quite a bit lower
from what i'm from what i'm used to and
what is
you know commonly done for these states
so in conclusion uh overall i think that
this method is definitely useful for
labs
wanting to quantitate a broad range of
pesticides
meeting various state cannabis
requirements
however there were a few shortfalls in
meeting all of the requirements of the
alac
snpr
and
the biggest issue
in the method development was the low
limits of quantitation for some of the
pesticides which were hard to meet
and
basically my focus in the method
development
keeping these these limits of
quantitation in mind
was to try to increase the sensitivity
of the method as much as possible
and the way that i approached that here
was to not dilute the sample
too much
which would effectively increase the
amount of analyte
that is being seen by the detector
and i think that that has definitely
contributed towards
some of the issues i saw with the matrix
effects
differences between the different
strains
one other thing that
i should mention as well is that i did
see
uh i did see some issues with with the
uh gcms inlet getting dirty
after repeated injections
and so i think that a further dilution
could also benefit there um
as far as the the gcms repeatability
and overall again i think it's uh
important for the industry moving
forward to consider the fact that
cannabis is a complex matrix
and as i've seen in this method
development what works for one type of
strain
might not work for another especially
when it comes to pesticide testing
and any potential future developments of
a standardized method for pesticides in
cannabis should keep this in
consideration
so thank you very much for your
attention
i'd like to again thank shimazu
scientific and military sigma for this
help
for their help with this project
and uh please uh feel free to reach out
to me
at the email address listed here thank
you very much
you